>>Karina: I'm going to ask a few of
you to share personal self evaluation
of your technique in the craft.
>>Lilia: In general, I'd like
to have greater contrasts,
clearer lines, darker lines.
>>Cristina: Our role as teachers in
the arts is to help the students move
from dependent learners
to independent learners.
And that very naturally
translates to them being able
to critically assess their own work.
>>Cindy: Students are attracted
to the school to study the arts.
They're starting to understand the arts,
understand themselves,
it's very motivating.
That's what the arts
brings to the learners.
>>Karina: Lay out your prints.
Let's try to pick the
strongest one in the bunch.
>>My goal is to get students to a
place where they can self appraise
and self evaluate their work
in terms of its strengths,
and aspects that need improvement.
But to be able to do that in a way they
can sort of envision the solutions,
and until they can do that, they're
always going to rely on outside voices.
>>Now the learning, again,
might just be an affirmation
of what you had been thinking,
it's just got confirmed.
>>Cristina: We take that whole process
of assessing their own production
and we break it down into steps.
>>Karina: I want to bring up a couple
of prints that former students have done
and a couple of mine working with
this intaglio drag point method.
>>Cristina: Students need to
see examples of great work.
And then the teacher has an
obligation to be able to speak
to what makes that work so great.
>>Karina: You're looking for
actually fuzzy, black, hazy line.
>>Bringing in a few of my prints,
and a few college level prints
that approach this project shows
them physically what the quality
of the final print should be.
>>Seem to get this beautiful rich,
I think just gorgeous blacks.
These awesome--
>>Cristina: That's the first
component, is breaking down what it is
that makes a work great, and then
beginning to provide students
with a vocabulary so they can access
that material in different ways.
>>Karina: You guys know that if
you say, "I like it, it's cool,"
what's the next thing I'm going to say?
>>Student: What about it
is nice and what's cool?
>>Karina: What about it
So I'm going to ask you to substantiate.
>>Lilia: You really get
focused on vocabulary
and making sure you have those words,
so that when you go into a critique,
you can not just say, "Oh, this
is kind of shady and strange."
You can be like, "Oh, this
is very nice contrast."
>>Karina: Why did you pick this one?
>>Student: It's darker.
>>Karina: And?
>>Student: It's clean as well.
>>Cristina: We begin with
very fundamental vocabulary,
so that by the time we
get to this point,
their ability to verbally articulate
around their work comes more
naturally to the students.
>>Karina: Why do you do critique?
>>Student: Because you learn through
error and not through success.
>>Karina: Fabulous.
>>As students are gaining an ability
to self assess, one crucial thing is
to give each student a chance
to give constructive feedback.
The Post-It note critique is a
way of having them all involved
and giving response to
everybody's piece.
They've all now responded to, let's say,
ten other people's works when they put
up the Post-It notes,
so they're exercising,
even if they're not verbalizing
those comments.
>>Lilia: It's a really good
opportunity to get really good feedback.
And when you can see patterns of
what is successful and unsuccessful
in somebody else's work, you
can then apply it to your work.
>>From my sticky notes, I got a
lot of "childish" and "exciting."
SO I think I definitely got the
childlike presence that I wanted in it.
>>Karina: You help them bit by bit,
thought by thought, to get to a point
of balanced self assessment,
where they know
where things lack or
need more adjustment.
They can anticipate some of
these corrections on their own.
>>Lilia: In terms of
improvement, I would have liked
to get a greater sense
of its abandonment.
>>Karina: Because at some point, some
of the students might just start to rely
on themselves and their own
intuition and to trust that.
So I think they're honing those skills.
>>Cristina: The power of arts education
is that the student and teacher begin
to recognize that every
student artist is unique,
and cultivate that student voice.
I think it's a very powerful
tool for learning.